holy smokes this show is brought to you
by datsusara
go to dsgear.com and use code word Joey
to get five percent off they're
extremely high quality functional gear
that's made with hemp textiles they have
bags geese rash guards and more like the
fanny pack that Joey loves so much go to
dsgear.com and use Cobra Joey to save
five percent show is also brought to you
by audit.com
go to audit.com and use code word church
to save 10 on all of their amazing
optimization products they have strong
bone extreme Tech immune stream tech
Sport and the famous Alpha Brain it's on
it.com use code word church
go
oh [__]
kick that [__] mulee I want you to
break the [__] speakers I want to
have to go to the doctor what is this
what are my pen kick this [__] this
ain't no Disney Channel let's go get the
people excited [__] there you go
[__] drop it lead sciati Jimmy
Schubert Joey Diaz it's a Wednesday
night [__] oh let's do this
[__] suck this lick it flick it stick it
oh [__]
it's Wednesday night you [__] moocs
let's put this [__] night together
huh kick that meal Lee kick that [__]
mule let's do this [__] this is the SOS
band this is when black people black
people they didn't give a [__] about
Oscars you know what I'm saying they
were just making music playing trumpets
that's it and that I'm suck a dance
oh
[__]
Wednesday June 29th
not the way I see it oh [__]
Bond hits for Trump [__]
almost electrocuted myself in Kick It
Lee
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joe here the Church of what's
happening now you [__] Savages out
there getting ready for the Fourth of
July weekend and [__] Flags hot dogs fat
[__] people with tattoos on their
calves they always got shorts to show
you the tattoo on the cat yeah I give a
[__] about that that tattoo on you
they're the parent on your calf I don't
even know what's going on with Chinese
people usually this time of the year you
see somebody Chinese they look at you a
little weird you know what I'm saying
because they got the goods
that don't happen no more we were kids
where'd you get firecrackers in Philly
and the Pollocks no you gotta get you
gotta send eight guys to go to Chinatown
because he talked to one Chinese guy
right he gave the money to the one
Chinese guy the guy went in an alley
then he came back and he gave you a bag
and he tried to get the [__] out of
Dodge yeah and by the time he got to the
corner you got to be a Kung Fu Fighter
because now four of them popped out of
garbage cans and [__] started taking
your fireworks but you know it's amazing
it was the oldest scam in the book I
said South Carolina guys would go down
to Florida and come back and they'd stop
in South Carolina
dude there was I remember it was a
business in the 80s man literally every
exit in South Carolina come get
everything and you could go and I'm
talking a stick of dynamite Lee yeah
before these [__] Isis right there in
South Carolina because the Dude would
you would talk to the dude and he'd feel
you out and you drop two or three
hundred then you look the dude in the
eye and you say what's in the van
and he go man you ain't no officer of
the law are you do I look like a [__]
officer alone we just smoked a doob what
do you got the [__] van man and the
guy would take his car keys out on his
left hand with two fingers on it oh yeah
yeah anyway it was the real [__] deal
with a hoof and a [__] wood leg and
he lost the leg in Vietnam he lost the
arm in [__] Iowa yeah I mean these
people are real Jack and they would have
fine fireworks they I remember one time
we bought a quarter stick of [__]
Dynamite like like a stick of like like
80 like a railroad it's gone below what
do you use Dynamite for we live on fire
not the tracks and then we ran like real
fast remember wrist Rockets remember
those wrist rocket things they would
like these things these metal things
were going to have these two it was like
a slingshot oh yeah yeah it was a wrist
rocket dude we would put the m80s in
there pull them back lady with the
cigarettes
boom over the neighborhood
just like boom this is crazy you know
they put a taboo on fireworks because
just like medical marijuana just like
everything else in like two retards come
along and [__] it up for everybody right
fireworks are [__] fun I I played
with fireworks I used to hold the whole
pack in my hand and light it until one
would go off and I just throw it in here
yeah he's like you're at a barbecue guy
had a cookout the guys but they drink
and he passes out in the lawn chair and
dive into a shoelace okay
and he's running across the front log
shops over the fence runs out in the
traffic trying to get away from the
fireworks fireworks are a [__] blast
but then you know the [__] uh with
the what's the stick
with the rain colors that come out of
the Roman Candle the Roman Candle the
stick would get hot and melt and people
would burn yeah you got you got to be
careful with that stuff you know I mean
[__] hilarious
dude there was a New York Giant yeah the
guy was a defensive line guy was messing
around he's still playing he just has
three fingers
he can still tackle with three fingers
get in there
I mean some people shouldn't mess around
with that stuff but other people can
handle it but no no you and you hear
them now like I've been hearing him at
night a couple people get [__]
enthusiastic in my old school you didn't
light a [__] firecracker to the
fourth and then when she got a couple
drinks in here there was always that bad
guy that shot a gun tremendous that's
when the party ended it was always that
one kid that smoked cigarettes he was
missing the tooth he already had a
tattoo you already quit high school you
know what I'm saying like he was just
bad news and he'd show up and go why are
you guys lighting fireworks let's just
shoot a gun who the [__] got a gun I
got one right here bad when that was it
we gotta go Doug this [__]
showed up with a gun okay hey why would
you show up to a gun to a firework party
man that's crazy how crazy is it out
here like I had never experienced it
because it was illegal in my town I'm
like the town all the times when I grew
up like I was just wide enough to be
like I never won bonded illegal anywhere
but like the only fireworks were like
that weekend I I like when I first
started dating my girlfriend who grew up
in Inglewood I would go down there
June 15th and they're already letting
fireworks and they go into like August
30th they go for like three months of
black neighborhood Mexicans oh yeah
those [__] great people crazy they
love all those fireworks and [__] oh
dude I was in a Shanghai like like a New
Year's New Year's my friend showed me a
video I came in like my buddy Butch
Bradley was over there and dude is he
still there no he goes over there yeah
he doesn't
where in the world is Butch Bradley it's
like Waldo where where the [__] is he's
all over the place dude these guys I
mean Kuala Lumpur Singapore Vietnam I
got a buddy of mine Matt Davis who's out
there dude it was a Mongolia and [__]
Mongolia doing stand-up comedy I mean
people don't realize dude
instead of Comedy is kind of uniquely
American art form the way we do it here
and now the internet's made the world
smaller so I was in Beijing I was doing
a one-nighter in Beijing China I know
it's ridiculous but I had a whole week a
whole bunch of stuff yeah I go yeah I
got in the the you go to Beijing and the
place called The Bookworm and you do
like you know they have people that
speak Chinese
doing stand-up in Chinese and then you
got uh like people who do it in in
English and this guy Dez Bryant who was
from originally from New York but now he
lives in Ireland but he was over there
doing a show trying to learn Chinese and
whatnot but it's crazy I mean you can
tour the world now legitimately in our
friend Tom Rhodes the guys out there all
over the place Rome Italy France
Amsterdam I mean all over the world like
legit or something personally yeah
I don't want to go nowhere no I I get it
listen when I got into comedy I looked
at the broad spectrum
I don't know what it was it looked at
the broad spectrum
and I liked doing comedy I like the
American Truck and this is when I had
the passport yeah I still was not too
[__] friendly about leaving the
country yeah I don't know why I I
it burns me out when somebody comes up
to me and said and I go who's that guy
he was funny like that such and such
he's [__] huge in Australia
but he's American you know it's like
somebody was telling me that uh Jimmy
Jeffries doesn't sell tickets in
Australia he only sells tickets in
America he sells tickets in America you
know it's vice versa but
um I never understood I always thought
the party was here I had an
understanding from the beginning I
wasn't going to be a stand-up comic I
didn't know about movies or TV we were
talking about this before this started
yeah but
there was something I wanted to do I
didn't know what I thought that the
stand-up would lead me
to somewhere else you know yeah and when
I got into it I said if I'm gonna do it
it's because when somebody comes up to
me this is a selfish statement to me
when somebody comes up to me like I had
a certain friend of mine that came up to
me crying one time
this and this I don't get spots at the
store nobody loves me I don't have a
agent and then a weak lady is telling me
how he's going to Belgium
for three weeks I go you know it's pilot
season yeah you know what what Belgium
what are you talking about what are you
[__] crazy but I I don't say those
things no more because it's really none
of my business right if you had the
choice between being in like a a lower
Market here let's say Detroit whatever
Market you want to say not La New York
or be like that in the top Market in
China
would you rather be in America like do
you think it's more valuable
there's there's uh at 1.8 billion people
in China dude even if 10 of those people
like you I mean you you're moving
tickets I mean but the funny thing is I
only do those trips because you know I
had been all over the United States I've
been to you know I started in Florida I
did some triple runs I could go to
Detroit for the tenth time or Chicago
for the night my brother I'm not here to
judge I'm just saying what was going to
work for me I don't know I feel weird
when I go into international waters I
never forget I got a [__] job in 2000
a movie in Jamaica I got fired but I was
happy because as soon as I saw those
chickens in Jamaica and I saw what those
people were eating that's when my party
ends I don't give a [__] how much reefer
they had I got out of there a day I was
in Jamaica for a day who goes to Jamaica
for a day Uncle Joey does yeah I don't
feel comfortable
I love to go to Cuba but I know at that
[__] anxiety button would hit yeah I
was especially if I got to sleep in
somebody's house on a [__] uh what's
that I got to go I got to go to Cuba I
did one of those Armed Forces
entertainment tours and we toured
through South America and I got to go to
Guantanamo Bay and do you know do shows
for the military over there so you're
actually in Cuba we had Sunday off they
got these pontoon boats we rent these
pontoon boats we go out into this one
area where we're allowed to go I'm out
there swimming looking for sand dollars
smoking is Cuban cigar and drinking beer
and we're hanging out with these guys
from the military base so you know
everything's groovy and I'm going I mean
where else and it was I think it was
Thanksgiving I mean it was like a
Thanksgiving we're sitting there we came
back we ordered some pizzas and we
watched the football games but I'm going
I want to do that stuff before you can't
do that stuff I mean you know I mean
Europe's gonna fall you can't I was in
bro I was just in Brussels and
Netherlands and I was in Kosovo I was in
Venice and we flew into Munich and we
did a couple weeks in Germany but I want
to see that stuff before you can't see
it anymore because eventually the way
the world's going I mean you know you
look look what happened in Istanbul the
other day I don't want to be in an
airport like that when that [__] happens
I got news for you God forbid but yeah
listen it's a cold reality you know I
was telling the people and uh
Philly because they understand my
[__] lingo you know they probably
they look at that uh when I got on the
plane I'm high it's 6 25 in the morning
you know I smoke on the way to the
airport I smoke at the airport and I get
sizzled at the house I have breakfast I
make a nice big healthy breakfast they I
have a protein smoothie but the duo that
I gotta get my appetite going I'm one of
those guys that has to have water coffee
and then I gotta wait an hour to get
hungry yeah you know I can't do that
because that food at the airport will
[__] kill you yeah it's bad that food
is the [__] airport I'll kill you
just the germs in that place would you
get off a handrail you know that's some
kind of you know get one of these little
kids one of these little carriers
walking around a petted a monkey in a
zoo and now he's got the handrail he had
the German actually flesh-eating
bacteria on your on your left foot and
these are all things that are funny to
us but it's a [__] reality no it is
I'm sitting there stoned and all of a
sudden
this lady walks on with the biggest dog
you ever saw in your lion and I'm
sitting there so I'm thinking that I
said how scared can she be she has no
idea that I've already put it in my mind
guys like you and I we're on the road 20
weeks a year that's 40 planes without
connectors
okay if you throw enough spaghetti
against the wall it sticks eventually
God forbid again we're gonna it'll end
up getting shot at one of those [__]
airports are blown up or a plane will go
down because we fly more than the usual
person yeah and I know the odds are high
against the plane going down but look at
all these planes going down in Europe
these guys already got the taste for it
these planes just didn't disappear I
love how the media tells you these
planes just disappear really what
happened where's the [__] these
planes just didn't disappear somebody's
shooting these [__] planes down and
you don't want to scare the airline
industry and the tourism industry by
saying it but this is a [__] fact do
you see what's happening in Brazil the
cops and stuff are like standing out
there like telling people not like
telling people that they're not gonna
get paid like there's Not Gonna Be Cops
for the for the Olympics yeah it should
be a good it should be an interesting
Olympic game some of those people may
actually have to do those things are
good at like run jump and throw you know
throw throw javelins of people just to
stay alive I mean just outside change
one of the dangerous places in the world
and there's no cops yeah plus I was
reading the story the other day all the
illegals coming across the border to
bring in tuberculosisville and
tuberculosis and Ricketts is making a
comeback because they're bringing all
that stuff in from the South of the
Border so it's yeah welcome to it bro
obviously that's awesome man welcome to
the 21st century right yeah Nostradamus
predicted it and we're seeing the roots
of it [__] get planted that's all I'm
telling you right now the roots and
whatever whatever [__] Nostradamus
says I don't know much about the sayings
I just know that every once in a while
you smoke a joint in the hotel on a
Thursday night you stay up a little late
and it's a story by Nostradamus on
discovering you caught it at 12 32. so
you got 28 hours to catch on to whatever
Nostradamus said but by that time
they're already saying how much of a
genius he was he foresold this he
foresaw that he foresaw this you know so
now you sit here and if you think about
what the [__] he said these are the
seeds of it uh [__] beast is gonna
come out of the whatever and who the
[__] knows you know yeah I mean just
just am I supposed to believe in the
Nostradamus I don't even know anymore
look like you said you you you worry
about what you can worry about change
your world hopefully it'll change the
world but you know we've gotten dumb
Riders of species I mean you look at
people right but the zombie apocalypse
I'm gonna look around it's over here
everybody's looking down at their cell
phone nobody's making eye contact no
one's having a conversation you walk
through the airport people are bumping
into each other walking that they can't
pay attention again I have a
conversation nobody talks to each other
anymore it's sad it's actually uh the
evolution I mean where everybody's kind
of hunched over we're kind of working
our way back down the evolutionary scale
you know I got a tweet I gotta take
pictures of my food I gotta I gotta go
let's pay to look up and live before you
get hit by a [__] car three of us
completely honest I get anxiety now
sometimes if I don't know where my phone
is or if I haven't like checked it for a
while like not if I'm doing something
but if I'm just sitting at home and
every like I can't find it or like I'm a
little bit bored just a tiny bit because
rehab now
to get people away from their phones yep
and there's rehabs now to stop people
from playing games this is a [__]
reason and I gotta tell you my old
schools I don't understand it you put in
a thing if it rings you answered if not
I don't want to play on my phone I'm
like listen man I don't have these
[__] stories
because I lived in a phone all because I
played Nintendo yeah or because I played
Super Mario or because I played Monopoly
or because I played any [__] games
these stories are because I never
[__] play games like most kids and
this is what I played instead the game
of [__] life and you get your ass
kicked and you get thrown out of places
and your credit goes bad and your wife
leaves you for other [__] people but
the game of life you gotta move forward
yeah so if you want to sit there and
look at your [__] phone and Twitter
and whatever listen I love Twitter and I
love Facebook but there's a time and a
place for it yeah exactly Saturdays and
Sundays I want to enjoy my life around
I'm in a hotel room I want to be
tweeting and taking pictures and showing
you whatever I love doing periscopes and
smoking dope with people but I don't
want to do it every [__] day I want
to keep you on edge I want to keep you
in suspense like [__] The Twilight
Zone you know what I'm saying
yeah it's it's uh it's getting it's bad
it's getting worse and it's just I just
I mean you know it's funny because none
of the other animals on the planet you
know the the you know you don't see a
you know a gorilla you know with a
device and then you know people don't
even realize all that technology the
radiation that machine creates to send
the signal in the space and bounce it
off the satellite and you're holding it
next to your [__] head everybody's
gonna have a brain tumor in the shape of
an iPhone 6. you know I don't know what
happened let me tell you you couldn't
shut the [__] up for 15 minutes and this
[__] thing's right next to your brain
goal I mean come on I don't understand
people walking down the street yeah on
the phone I don't understand
like people walking and not paying
attention I see it every morning because
I walk my daughter because it's more
entertaining I walk past people that are
looking on the floor
and thinking about that conversation I
gotta know but nothing to say to nobody
while I'm [__] walk in that phone
could ring I look at it if it's not 310
that phone ain't getting [__] picked
up but
you have no idea yeah I know the phone
people think I [__] around when I'm out
and about and I'm doing business I got
two or three people around me and [__] I
just had to call that girl back right
because I haven't spoken to her she left
me a couple we've been playing phone
with that besides that if you call me
now I don't give a [__] yeah my phone is
a way for me to keep in touch with the
world it's not a way for you to call
Mayor like I check my Facebook status I
mean you know as my nephew would come
over again when my left you my nephew
live with me for like a year and a half
he's up there and you know come home
from work he you know he drink Red Bulls
and then Cheetos and you know a kid live
like a rock star he never left the house
he's on Facebook and social media I'm
going dude you gotta go out and live it
a little bit
I you know I'm trying to write a book
and I outlined and I outlined and
outlined I'm to a part right now I'm
about 17 and a half
and Jimmy this time I gotta stop and cry
I gotta stop and cry
I'm up to the part right now where
everybody really didn't know I was
living with a family they were feeding
me I wasn't paying rent I was going to
high school I had friends
smoking dope I was selling a few pills
you know and I didn't know what the next
day it was going to be I was just in the
back of my mind hoping that the death
certificate was wrong you know what I'm
saying like hoping that my mother wasn't
dead I would go by the house every day
just to see if maybe she was at the
track or something that's how crazy it
got you you know
but I'm thinking about the events I used
to do like I'm trying a list of events
and I get sad
because I got friends who have kids and
their kids weren't doing what I was
doing at [__] 17 and a half yeah It
embarrasses the [__] out of me then
Paris is the [__] [__] out of me well
it was different times dude and you know
you did like I didn't well why didn't I
stay home and play Mario Brothers why
did I stay home on a Saturday night like
most kids don't watch cyanide live and
on Mondays they were giggling the
hallway but you said to yourself you're
busy making [__] stories you can't do
that [__] look you know you can't you
know Sam Kinison used to do a bit about
like you can't write those bits unless
you live those stories you know when
they're out you're drunk you pass out
and you wake up and your head's you lay
right next to a [__] grilled really
big grilled ham and cheese sandwich oh
that looks like you know [__] Dr
Bruce [__] you know but you can't write
that joke unless you pass out and say
you wake up next to the sandwich gone
you know I mean I don't mean but you
know the other thing is too I think
about you know my motorcycle accident
almost losing my [__] leg all that
stuff you don't you don't have [__]
time to like probably you should be in
[__] therapy after stuff like that
happens to you and try to work through
it and figure it out you don't you don't
have [__] time and you can't afford
to because [__] life's [__] moving
you know you gotta you know there was a
you know a couple times where you go oh
I [__] what I was even thinking I I
should have I mean I I didn't even know
how that would have affected me or you
know it does I mean you know we know
more about it now than we did back then
but Jesus I mean well you don't know
you're going through it why are you
going through it yeah exactly so you
pass it and then you sit there one day
and go wow what I was going through that
situation
was a little [__] up yeah
and it's like I lost 10 pounds when that
person stopped talking to me or it was
just a weird situation at that time but
you don't know you're going through it
while you're living through it it's just
a bad day after another you know it's
weird when you see somebody going
through a bad patch in their life
you know you see people who
three years just bump into a bad passion
in that life and a lot of things could
happen in those three years you could be
weak enough to join Isis in this society
today you could join Isis because you're
weak and you couldn't pay your mortgage
and you hated the government you know
you could get a gun and go to Kmart and
shoot 18 people and shoot yourself you
can shoot the dog there's so many
options out I didn't have those options
yeah well because you know you say what
the [__] you want but you never did that
I mean dude everybody goes through a lot
of [__] I think the way you handle
adversity I mean but you but you think
about like like mental illness in this
country and there's a book out called
the sociopath that lives next door and
they talk about all these different
mental illnesses such a stipulation on I
mean I would never even entertain the
idea of running through a [__] Kmart
with an AK-47 and just killing [__]
people you know as bad as things got I
never did anything like that and but
you're right you know sometimes you got
to get through it and you stop for a
minute you look back and you remember
going wow that I'm [__] I'm lucky I
made it alive I'm still on the right
side of the grass I'm still breathing
I'm still I'm still in there fighting
I'm still pushing that [__] rock up
the hill I'm still trying to live the
good life I mean you know I grew up in
the in the 90s and early 2000s which is
like early like the like the start of
the Pacifica whatever you want to call
it but generation snow for like I still
remember in elementary school the kids
who we hated were the crybabies the kids
who would cry if he didn't if he didn't
do anything to him or or always always
just complained rewind and it seems like
we're not doing that anymore like it
seems it seems like the crybabies have
the internet
and they're very vocal yeah and they're
like the whole world's upside down in 90
I I was outlined you know I'd be that
way in the last month or so just because
you have to know what you're going to
write about in the future and sometimes
you get stuck like let me do work on
something else and I was thinking about
94. like I live in a one-bedroom Rocky
apartment there was a bench a Sony
Trinitron a couch a mattress and a room
that the mattress was so big it took the
whole room you couldn't open and close
the door there was no furniture in there
it was just a mattress you just fell in
the bed sometimes I wouldn't even change
the sheet you know it was one of those
things and it was my Rocky apartment and
at that time I was so happy to have that
apartment but I had this [__]
loneliness at that time I didn't know I
was going through it until years later
yeah until a couple weeks ago I was
writing it out the loneliness I had like
I was doing stand up I had friends but
when I would go home at night it was the
loneliest I'd ever been
I'd be [__] alone with my blow and a
fat tie every 90 days I bumped into a
freak at the gas station and she came
over and
you know something creepy happens or
something but I was so lonely as a soul
you know I don't even know I in 85
before I left New Jersey I was on the
lurk I was hiding so from January to
June I was always by myself and I don't
forget that birthday eating at my
favorite Chinese restaurant in Fort Lee
by myself on my [__] 22nd birthday or
something
and now I think about how lonely I was
even though then the back of my mind I
thought it was okay my night was made
I'm gonna eat some Chinese food walk
over the bridge get a ten dollar bag of
reefer
and then just walk to like a hundred and
something take a train down and come
around the other end you know I was
pretty happy in those days
it's [__] crazy the land of the
robbing that Chinese restaurant what are
you gonna do you understand I went in
there for lunch one day the Chinese
people wouldn't give me a tab and the
register's right there on the way out I
just hit it there was 20 years I lifted
up there was a couple fifties I ran out
of it I went back a week later because
they had tremendous Szechuan shredded
beef you know what I'm saying did they
catch you no
[Music]
in those days I was just got an eyeball
and I would go in there one day on the
way out I'm sitting there for the
[__] time
they're not coming out they're in the
back talking arguing I'm sitting by the
register nothing I finally hit the
registered opens up
I just made out the [__] door a week
later I said nobody saw them let me go
in there and test them I deny it
I went in there they served me like
usually I looked around make sure there
was no spitting there no Chinese
eyeballs
and I was clear I kept going back in and
then another time I went in there for
once and did the same thing I robbed
them again then I moved to Colorado and
I never went back then I went back and
they were out of business so
everything's forgotten charges have been
dropped Chinese restaurant owners all
over Colorado who like speak about you
and I was like you know how many Chinese
restaurants have you never raised like
four was that place on Sunset boys walk
we had them on point two in there too
for a while I had them on delivery the
rock and roll raps ah hilarious [__]
always walk behind always walk was a
place called JJ's beepers
when I first moved here JJ beepers had
signs all over Sunset if you had a
beeper or you wanted a cell phone you
went to [__] J and JB because
then the chicks book came out
Heidi Fleiss and he was Heidi fleiss's
partner
so he ran in that business I saw that
business go from a [__] mall it was
right behind always walk right the
reason why did we go to Hawaii's walk
because it's so good no because there
was a head shop place behind it you [__]
that's still there you said you said
it's the best it's the best seven dollar
Chinese oh please for seven dollars
absolutely are you [__] kidding me I
had that neighborhood down you got an
egg roll a cup of soup noodles which is
big if you get that thrown in some
people know they see me coming they
charge me 50 cents a bag but some people
don't even see me coming they just keep
going those noodles you dope that super
but those noodles that's an air pocket
in your stomach that [__] goes a long
way later on you know what I'm saying
when you're living on a [__] thread
those noodles are tremendous let me get
some more dry noodles absolutely and you
get that [__] Kung Pow that comes
with noodles and you add more and you
keep eating that [__] fills you up that
says when you're not worried about your
measurements this is when you're just
trying to survive yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah when you're trying to
survive there's nothing like a Chinese
we got a comedy store and we had it down
we knew it's happy hours you go hit a
happy hour and they would put out the
free food you know uh tacos and and you
could have three free joints
what would you guys do to the lunch
buffet yeah but this was just happy
today we just people would just put food
out and you go oh yeah that place is and
not only at the time there was only one
lunch buffet excuse me and I really
liked Italy and I haven't been there in
five years and I'm thinking of going
next week Acapulco oh a Mexican lunch
buffet there was two Acapulcos in town
here there was one where the sports bar
is now on La Brea and sunset right down
the block from Hawaii's walk if you're
headed east there's a bar there now that
you go to the right now they used to
have Sons of Anarchy Nightmare and and
they somebody did comedy they'd have an
upstairs on
you and me went there we saw the
waitress okay that that place that place
used to be in Acapulco oh okay when I
first moved here in 1997 that place was
Acapulco but the other Acapulco is an
echo like if you stay on Sunset right
once you pass a Scientology Center on
the right you go that right there's an
Acapulco there tremendous lunch special
what do they have six dollars they have
like some type of [__] meat with
onions and [__] the [__] rice is
delicious they would have the soup would
be off the [__] chain and they would
have condiments you could dope it up and
spice it up they'd have tamales not the
best tamales you got salsa you had chips
you had cheese you could enchiladas you
know but for listen when you're [__]
struggling and you got six seven eight
ten bucks
you could [__] kill it dad though you
could kill that [__] pill you
get to the comedy storm borrowed 20 for
a late dinner right or wrong yeah I
should have hold you over till 10 15.
you could borrow a 10 from Jeff the
piano player to go get a sandwich over
at [__] pink dot what I'm talking
about is survival
you get up like always walk in those
days I wouldn't walk into it something
happened somebody found the mouse on an
egg roll and that was the end of that
[__] deal
if you know what we got one morning and
when the word spreads yeah it's like
Clint Eastwood came to town The Outlaw
Josie Wales the word
spreads we were going in there a long
time they had a tremendous Kung Pao
[__] chicken
they had a tremendous lunch special and
then somebody found the mouse and it was
all over and I had to switch governments
over to the [__] Boogie joint
the one across from rock and roll rocks
that used to be my office that had a pay
phone out front next to the [__]
Russian deli
right across from Rock and Roll Ross
right now there's a weed store on that
corner that used to be a magazine store
for 20 000 [__] years yeah
you used to run book out of that I did
everything I saw a blow out of there I
[__] weighed Coke in there
I forget the name of it I used to I used
to go there
six times a [__] week
wow
and you went in an office
listen [__] nut
the restaurant was so big you made Coke
in the restaurant listen to me the
restaurant was so big they had all the
door that you opened up and ran away you
had like eight boot type style tables
and then they had a fish tank
if you went around that fish tank they
had a little private room back there
like tables that you could sit like this
so I would show up five deep you know I
had lunch with that Anderson Silva
I took Anderson Silva [__] that to
lunch with his manager and his whole
[__] team
they were like why do we go eat in
Hollywood like I'll meet you and I took
him in there we ate Chinese food like
kings they even thought no no they don't
throw in a can of soda they just throw
in the basics the soup the [__]
noodles glass of water the egg roll it
tastes like ass that you trade for a
[__]
fried rice I'll give you my egg roll
because you don't get pork fried rice
they give me that vegetable like fried
rice but when you throw the [__] beef
on top of it it'll taste the same at the
end I get it with white rice anyway why
are we talking about Chinese [__]
lunch specials [__] Turkish people
are [__] getting blown up 42 at
discount and the beauty of it is tonight
I'm watching World News Tonight and
they're interviewing [__] uh a couple
who going to Turkey you know what man
house you know everybody wants to be a
[__] hero the other night I got
sucked into that movie about the
Avalanche the [__] people who go to
the top of the mountain and then they
started dropping like flies and I'm
thinking to myself and all 20 of those
people that went up there I didn't see
one Spanish person or one black person
because they don't think about that [__]
nobody wait a second you got a chance of
never coming back and you want to climb
a mountain what is the [__] purpose
what is the I never saw the [__]
movie I'm sitting there I watch it
because of the actors yeah to say we did
it yeah because it was there and kill
yourself camp and the balloons selfie
and you got to go in the winter and
there's storms up there and lightning
and then okay that's nice you want to
walk halfway and take a picture and mind
your business and go home I'm with you
but you're gonna go up there and pitch a
[__] tent like some [__] only certain
crazy [__] people do but there's also
people who watch the Periscope today and
said Joey did 18 [__] bunks that's
just ridiculous so you know what I'm
saying people who live in uh glass
houses shouldn't throw stones that's
some [__] story and I I
obviously it's not gonna do anything
against the bomb but I was actually
thinking about like like what what about
getting bulletproof vests I know it's
not gonna do anything against the bomb
or a plane going down but and do what
with at least wear it have you ever put
a bulletproof vest on nope okay they
weigh 22 [__] pounds on top of what
I'm walking with in luggage that's
number one number two listen Lee
when it's time to go
it's time to go
unless you get 20 000 and get one of
those thin shirts that is bulletproof
but what look at the size of your head
in the mirror when you go home it's
pretty tough to miss that [__] thing
from a thousand yards you could hit my
[__] head with a [__] peanut and a
[__] potato thing are you crazy
unless they make head guard for us that
even our eyeballs because you we're all
luck we're gonna hit no one eyeball
that's open you know to be honest I mean
you're just saying you have to go out
and live and live and make stories
how can you you have to be a little
scared now to go out to malls and bars
and I stay away from large groups of
people that's one maybe that's why
people go do that what they try to do
with Mount Everest to get away because
you know there's not going to be a crowd
of people there yeah but but you know
avoid any place you know they like soft
targets and they like high number counts
but I mean we got to travel for a living
but I'd stay away from like you know
soccer games and listen everybody in
this country everybody who listens to
this podcast across the world
is in danger
you've got to get coffee now yeah that's
something that pulls out a gun right
here in America we don't even you know
you have the threat of Isis but we also
have the Homegrown Patriots to be poor
angry at the government's a bunch of
people look at this chanted man yeah but
I'm telling you like I mean that's the
thing I'm just supposed to get [__]
used to this now I mean this is just
like a new trend I'm not always supposed
to be evolving or it's moving towards
this [__] you know you know Starfleet
and the one Federation or you know I I
mean we're we're animals we're [__]
Barbarian world uh
Lee's educated
your Edge your fault is a cop you will
raise Irish Catholic
I mean three of us would have an
uneducated answer to this [__]
question
what's the educated answer to what's the
next step does it listen in one step
right here I call a guy by the name of
Ross Perot and I break it down I go Ross
what would you do in this situation
what do you think Ross Perot would do
he's like making them a [__]
memory
you just can't do that
and that's eventually going to happen
because they're going to do something
somewhere that's just the wrong place
you blow up Disney
that's Chinese
you don't want those missiles coming at
you well if I can uh Barack Obama the
the Drone Ranger uh the drona ranger uh
set out [__] took out 250 [__]
Isis people right after today
250 Isis Fighters gone today
that's like throwing gasoline on a fire
yeah that's like [__] spraying that
spray on a on a beehive yeah and the
back end of the bees get away and now
they get together and they get even more
pissed off right and now they go to plan
B which could be a chemical attack now
they go to plan B which could be a
[__] a Fourth of July celebration now
they go to plan C that could be a UFC
event God forbid a Major League Stadium
NFL listen to me listen to me and it
doesn't take this is where my stupid ass
could tell you something
you mess around
with one of those football stadiums
on the Lord's day during the NFL season
my heart goes out to you I can't help
you
because they're going to have every gun
loving toting American who watches
Sports in this country and big money
big money listen the NFL is Big Money
the NFL is big money like you said my
favorite movies concussion very
entertaining wasn't it I didn't see
anything yeah but Dr Solani says they
got their own [__] day they got their
own day Sunday they own a day and the
week and how sad is that that you're
right
have you ever been laying in the bed and
go okay so you bombed 42 people at a
club in Orlando [__] them it's a [__]
travesty that's right it burns my heart
you know you do this you do that you
shoot up whatever happened today at what
point in America does the general public
say listen
for [__] two of my pennies every
[__] year go to one of these bombs
you [__] promise it's time to
put those [__] to test
well you know you know and the next
thing is is like [__] people taking
matters into their own hands I mean
going if you're not gonna [__] if you
can't even [__] say the word if you
can't [__] defend me then I know
where exactly what these [__] how
long before someone walks into a mosque
and [__] murders 50 people in a
[__] mosque and how long before that
starts happening the other [__]
Direction I'm just saying people have
had a [__] enough I mean you know we
grow up you try to play by the rules
you're not they're not even playing by
the same set of [__] rules they could
give a [__] they strap on a [__]
suicide vest and take out as many
[__] people as they can they want to
drag everybody back to a [__] you
know 5 BC and I'm gonna you know I I
don't understand it I don't I don't know
you know that and that [__] hatred
that kind of [__] hate is taught and
it's taught from when you're a little
[__] kid and that you could actually
just walk in and just [__] annihilate
50 people on my worst day on my worst
day [__] you know with my [__]
guns you know I wouldn't [__] walk in
and shoot anymore my worst day I
wouldn't [__] do it I'd lay in the
[__] bed and [__] pop in a movie
I'd [__] drink myself so like on my
worst day would never [__] go in and
harm another human being I mean I I just
okay but listen to this people have
mental health issues well that's that's
a whole people that one day they're
sitting there with a gun that they're
gonna kill themselves and now those
voices outside are at the [__] local
supermarket you know I want you to do
something real quick for me because I do
it [__] once a week as a reminder I
do it maybe sometimes on Saturday nights
Just Close Your Eyes
and think of being at your favorite
sandwich shop with your [__]
girlfriend Lee Jimmy shoe but you travel
to Chicago you're with this [__]
attorney and you're minding your own
business and all of a sudden you hear
[__] high artillery gunfire
that's a reality you know that's a
reality that's a reality today when you
leave the house you gotta kiss the cat
now you're gonna hug the dog and say you
know what it was a good one
I don't know if I'm gonna go back I
gotta go to the [__] Ralphs because
now you don't I mean it's [__] sad it
I feel bad for my daughter I feel bad
for children who are 13. I gotta see
this every day in Disneyland you know
listen they do something to Disneyland
what do you think happens
Let's Pretend in your father's imaginary
as an American they [__] put a bomb
inside Disneyland which I hear security
is [__] tremendous now I hear
security is so good at Disneyland it's
annoying
this is from a friend of mine that is a
habitual Disneyland guy wow that's
correct and but that's true but I mean
if they're wearing a bomb all they have
to do is get up to the ticket area
can you imagine what would you think
what would be the public outcry I mean
the public outcry would be the only way
you're gonna we're gonna vote for you is
if you say what we want to hear I think
it's already at that though no it's
already out there you even look at you
know the brexit I mean everybody yeah
we did it first we were the original
[__] brexit [__] have you
seen the have you seen the videos of
what's going on over there like it's
like they're like even more like racist
anti-muslim stuff they're yelling at the
month yeah but you know what because
they want their [__] country back
they want the [__] [__] back they
want some sovereignty you know the
European Union [__] rules them like
that they override their judges they
tell them who can get into their [__]
country and these people like you know
they want their [__] lives back I
don't [__] blame them I mean you know
we can't if we're not moving in the
direction of [__] Starfleet and
[__] everybody gets along and live
long and [__] Prosper all that [__]
if we're not having a spiritual [__]
Revolution and everybody's gonna start
blowing [__] people up then by all
means shut it down
I'll tell you something guys guys I
don't know there's a reason and the
movie sleep is
when the guys are talking politics at
the bar and the guy from sleeper says go
over there and tell them a change of
conversation is necessary no religion
and no Politics the same thing is
happening to me right now this is one of
the first podcasts in a long time I've
done that I just got stressed out for a
minute yeah so we're going to change
this change the subject there's nothing
we could do to change it no what we were
talking about that was interesting was
Saturday night I'm in the [__] Green
Room at Helium the weekend went great
and uh Eleanor brings her two brothers
and Billy and Johnny or whatever [__]
great guys yeah they're great and as
they leave and I go to it's funny you
know Schubert's Brothers showed up
that's [__] weird and I go to the
hotel I sleep two hours I get up I go to
the airport thank God I got up early and
went and got two eggs
the [__] greasy spoon around the
corner from the hotel because there was
nothing to eat at that [__] Philly
Airport yeah it was early the pizza
place was closed there was a pizza place
when I landed on the way out like oh
[__] there's breakfast on Sunday a nice
little slice of [__] pizza but to go
[__] they had those old [__] cancer
eggs with that French toast that looked
like [__] debt thank God thank God I
ate that but I'm sitting there minding
my own business yeah Schubert's brother
didn't come and who comes [__]
hopping along with Jimmy Schubert at the
airport happy as a pig and [__] it's a
725 [__] flight he's a professional
you see what I'm saying my flight was at
5 30. I flew from Pittsburgh to Philly I
get there and I'm catch I'm catching a
730 connector and and uh they they the
and then I you call my name I turn
around it's Joey Coco Diaz as a living
breathe sitting there by himself away
from all the fight I'm gonna turn them
by myself and then when you came over
then the couple sat in front of us and I
had the [__] because it was a
Dominican Republic so next thing you
know I had [__] Telemundo in front of
me I had them all around me and I'm like
Jesus Christ how'd this happen now nice
no it was a Dominican cup behind me it
was cool as [__] but we were you know we
were talking about comedy and how in
we were going to always walk and you had
a deal and you took me to lunch and you
showed me where to get headshots in that
place there used to be another place
that we used to go to but the dude died
and left the Chinese Widow and then one
night coked up I called her up and asked
if I could eat a monkey in Chinese
you learned how to say it no I just
asked him right out there was a place
that's now a porn video Russian place
okay so Rock and Roll Ross is rock and
roll rocks okay
this is crazy [__] rock and roll Ralphs
is rock and roll rocks okay right over
here is the wheat store the Russian Zone
with Natasha and then I used to get a
haircut there just till two years ago
from 1997 to three years ago I got a
haircut there every six weeks at that
place I went back to that neighbor I
always loved that neighbor it's just if
you're not doing blow and getting your
dick sucked and going out every night
you shouldn't live there like when you
said I think I should move down because
you're going to hear sirens all night
the valley is quiet
you moved to Hollywood you hear screams
and yells and it's for Chase's [__]
crazyly you know you go to Rouse in Hot
in Hollywood at 2 30 in the morning a
day to go to russet a quarter to
rock and roll rocks and see how many
people going in by [__] case is a bit
because the place is shutting it too
that place I've seen people from all
sizes going ahead according to people
online join
online knowing that this is it this is
the final frontier ah God that
neighborhood is great but on the other
side of that rock and roll ROMs there's
raffaello's Pizza
there's a flower place and they used to
be a headshot place and you went and
then the guy looked like uh
oh good busting loose with Richard Pryor
Gene Wilder Gene Wilder they look like
Gene Wilder gained 200 pounds his hair
was crazy he had glasses he had a wart
on his face and he had this German
Shepherd that was older than he was he
was he had that guy was [__] ready to
die even the dog wanted to die they had
head shots in there Mickey Rooney like
the guy had been there with everybody
yeah for the old Hollywood oh wow
somewhere along the line he picked up
Yoko Ono Junior but the difference
between Joseph
and the real alcohol yo yo whatever Yoko
Ono was that this chick was banging
I mean you just went there to get your
head shots developed you know how these
people talk about cougars this chick
must have been about 49. she had to have
breast redone you know she dressed nice
she [__] and you can look at her and
go oh this chick's a party it didn't
take you long to know that this chick
was a Party Ricky Cruz was out here then
me you Ricky showed there was 30 people
who got their head shots done there yeah
we all went in there and he was family
he let you take it on the arm and come
back a week later you can pay him a
little bit pay him a little bit because
in those days it was 129 dollars for 300
headshots yeah now you know what it is
22.50 for a hundred of them because
they're dying to give them away they'd
only use headshots in Hollywood no more
no I know it's all electronic so people
are like [__] we'll give you a
picture we'll take a picture and give it
to you for free just come and use our
machines yeah there was a place on
across from Rock and Roll Rouse that was
huge it was like a printing World dead
done they're down to a little [__]
one little Korean dude and a [__] uh
by himself and they're gonna please
schedule artists will you see how the
business has changed in so many animals
but anyway the [__] we go in there
over the holidays you know every January
every January you get new headshots so
we went in there one day and the place
is closed it's been a death in the
family
what the [__] happened all right maybe
the old man's mother died we wanted but
when the week it's open
I go there
and the wife is there like what's going
on where's Mickey and she goes Mickey
passed away and she started crying and I
could see her cleavage and right away
I'm getting bad thoughts like a porno
movie I'm gonna take her in the back and
give her a stabbing over all this Agony
and [__] I was all cooked up
I was walking around with a [__]
sexual overtone you know what I'm saying
in those days I'd see a [__] chick
homeless and I'd have thoughts but you
know when you're doing blood and [__]
your [__] miners you know you want to
talk about oh my God a part of my you
know people always hit me up with
addiction questions and I tell them
listen get the [__] out of that I know
you got a problem I know how it was I
know it's going to take a while to think
about it but do yourself a favor get out
of there because once you're out of
there you're going to look back you know
how and I always say this you know how
white people walked out of Amistad
covering their faces yeah that's what
you do by yourself at night when you
think of some of the [__] you did on the
Coke and what you did for the Coke and
what time you had to go and when you
borrowed money from so I think of all
that [__] addiction [__] yeah and
that's another thing that you look at
and go what where the [__] was my head
at yeah well maybe you know I and I
actually experience it like maybe you
don't realize and you were
self-medicating because you didn't know
how to [__] handle it let me ask this
question I don't interrupt nobody but I
don't even know what's up man [__] dude
you have [__] [__] going on for years
people talking about son he's
self-medicating I do a couple bumps from
time to time
nobody know what I'm saying but bro yeah
that's the problem with that [__]
there's no there's no a couple bumps
here a couple bumps there but before you
know it [__] seven o'clock in the
morning I saw a kid doing coke
supposedly on Periscope last night and
it finally happened
I will say this though I'm glad social
media wasn't around when I was doing
that [__] listen at the point I was at
in 2006 if Periscope was around and I
knew what I knew now
one o'clock in the morning I'd rent a
hotel room from a space unknown I'd have
somebody else go in there with a fake
name so the cops couldn't even find me I
changed the hotel room around I'd take
an eight ball and just snowing on camera
making noises
show me crawling on the floor and I
would charge like 22.50 a minute
and I would be the number one show on
the internet John
hiding looking from cameras smoking
[__] sheetrocket working the people
working the people we had the people
people when you stayed in a handicap
room you had you had you had two peoples
you had the regular people and you had
the handicapped people and if you get it
there and you did you worked oh my God
you can work both people you won't wake
up in the morning like a raccoon you got
little black eyes oh my God I would work
a peephole I would work the [__]
underneath I would lay on my floor and
look underneath the door thing and look
for feet walking by in Shadows and [__]
you have no idea Lisa no I I've heard
stories dude I've always said like yeah
what's the most paranoid you've ever
gotten you hear that stuff it's crazy
what story one night I got so paranoid
with you up here in [__] Gotham City
there I had basketball the next day I
was shooting basketball and we went to
your house and we drank a gallon of red
wine you were saving for sauce on Sunday
you had I had to argue with you for an
hour with Jimmy we got to drink the wine
my girlfriend's family Jimmy I don't
give a [__] about your girlfriend's
family we gotta drink this red [__]
wine I don't give a [__] we drank the
red wine I get home at six they call my
calls at seven [__] Thirty and I'm
the first scene up I've never shot
nothing in my life here I am at the
[__] Coliseum downtown coming down
off of cocaine benches
with spaghetti and meatballs and Monday
night cookies were you talking about my
[__] God I'm like forget about all
that prediction [__] this started as a
simple night go go Diaz I got an
audition tomorrow come over we'll read
the sides and we'll [__] eat some
spaghetti yeah I'm having my sauce I
invited call the ball over too so you me
you don't call caught on show we went
over the sides for a minute and then you
went in the back and you found the
package from 1982 and you got it started
and that was it yeah we'll do one more
one more one more can you call your guy
how much you got 60 I'll put in a
hundred next thing you know it's four in
the morning you got one window oh my God
a shitty couch I had a futon I had a
stupid desk with a [__] computer and
that's all I [__] have besides the
clothes in my back that was like my
Rocky joint out here remember that
little apartment had a nice little
kitchen but it was like I mean dude I
had you know that's what I I was you
know you were one of the last people
that was so embarrassing to me that
night like you never repeat it you
didn't remember because you were looking
at your own window you were having your
own dilemma yeah and I was having my own
dilemma and I am I said that's never
going to happen again I can't get
paranoid around people yeah at that
point I was getting half paranoid if the
chick was around I would get half
paranoid if I would get coked up with
somebody and they got paranoid it was
over yeah I remember one time I smoked
crack I was on probation in Boulder
Colorado oh wow I'm on [__] federal
probation
and at this time my body was suing
people left and right I had a friend in
Jersey all he had to do was get rain
done and he'd get dirty G's he had this
Jew attorney that was ruthless
this guy sued a guy on a bike that was
going down the street got cut off by a
car hit the sidewalk bumped into his
wife you got 130 grand for that this guy
was suing people left him right he was
carrying the bathtub he'd cut his finger
160 and he snorted
every dollar till then yeah
um one of his Coke fiends you know he
would just call me and go hey die hey
coach I'm thinking they're coming up and
he just jumped on a plane with some
other [__] sketch and they'd be going
for two days and they'd get here with
three eight balls and we get a hotel in
balls and the number one night we're
sitting there playing simple cards and
they're like you never smoked it before
I'm like I never smoke crack and they
cook and crack in the microwave and I
took two or three hits and guys I was
hiding in the shower because I was on
probation yeah they got Coke on them you
know on the way to the hotel if you see
a cop eating a hamburger even though
he's eating a Hamburg in your mind he's
there to watch you it is the creepiest
paranoia yeah and you keep doing it and
doing it you know they've said they've
said that you know and uh and yeah
because towards the end I think I wore
out of gear and that's that's what it
was when you get you would it was no
longer fun you would just get that
paranoid but I mean it was they said at
the height of cocaine paranoia you your
brain Rivals that of a schizophrenic
like schizophrenics that's what they
feel all the time and until I forgot I
said wow that's what's against a friend
that goes through every day all the
[__] time I feel [__] bad for him
I gotta tell you could you imagine that
I mean going through like that living
your life like that I mean that's what
like a schizophrenic is that all the
time you feel that way I [__] love
that
love that one you know listen man
from
from 70 from 80 to like 81 and a half
I would buy a grandma called I was a
junior in high school let's say
I would get a half a gram from this kid
who recently died
and I would do a couple lines out
because the kids I was hanging with did
drugs but they didn't do bumps
but I was living in my own world what do
you mean they didn't do much they did
what they did acid and we smoked dope
but at that time there was only two or
three of us out of the nine that did
bumps and the three of us that didn't
want those other six to know we were
doing it right we just didn't want them
to know so I I would get to do a bump in
the bathroom and drink with them because
I can't drink
so for me to drink in those days I would
I knew I had to do a couple [__] so I
do a couple bumps drink nine to ten
beers and then I would go home I would
sit in the dark Jimmy shoot but with
earphones on and just listening doing
bumps and crying and jerking off and
going through with [__] uh
Denzel Washington went through on Man on
Fire and he would put the gun to his
head and I didn't have a gun in those
days but I would go through the
psychosis you know I know for a fact I
can name numerous times where the
cocaine went into a state of psychosis
where we saw cops the next day it was a
[__] fire hydrant where I saw the
curtains move and I'm not [__] crazy
I saw the guy's hands stick his fingers
and enclosure right away you know I saw
I dumped an ounce of coke one night I
saw a [__] I don't like I said I
thought there were dogs it was a fire
hydrant sticking up in my mind one night
I saw people on ropes dressed in white
with those furs
like 007 with the machine guns coming
down from the trees in Colorado I was in
a trailer on a [__] furlough
it's not an eight ball Coke fell on my
hands and knees licking I think these
guys are coming into the [__] door
I'm jerking off in a [__] bathroom in
a trailer how many times I jerked off on
a plane coked up in a [__] bathroom
I'm embarrassing this is yeah that was
that's a that's the that's a [__]
embarrassing drug I mean you telling
these stories dude my stomach oh my God
oh my God the sickness of like you know
because it wasn't I mean there was a
point where you overdid it wasn't it it
wasn't fun anymore and I just said I'm
not [__] doing it anymore I'm just
not and I'm glad I did I'm glad I
outgrew it because I you know I had a
runner and you know I dude I you know I
was doing with Kennison I mean this guy
was gonna [__] you know like an ounce
I mean the [__] was always available I
mean back then it was just uh different
times but people giving it it's like
weed now yeah he was Sam Kennison who
didn't want to be able to say I just did
some blind I just delivered the cat that
was the kindness oh you're so who
wouldn't can you imagine but being able
to do a bump with Sam County
Billy Idol's doing bumps his [__] you
know Ted Nugent hanging around he wasn't
partying but I mean there's a but I mean
there's all these [__] rock and
rolling he's looking at David Lee Ross
doing look at his little pinky now what
if I got only backstage the universal
amphitheaters and Ginger Baker was
playing was one of the drummers in the
[__] rock and roll all-star band with
[__] uh I mean it was [__] insane
I mean now he isn't there you know
gingerbreakers playing drums CeCe
DeVille from [__] poisons on guitar
yeah this guy from Toto he had all these
everybody's cooked up I did it so the
gills to the gills like it was they were
the [__] greatest thing that that
time in life and I I know what they
would go like The Comedy Store listen
the first time I walked in The Comedy
Store I thought about two things
I thought about comedy and I thought
about my party in life how everything's
just gotten taken care of
you know so when you're an open mic you
got to go do your comedy and The Comedy
Works but you got to go to Aurora to
pick up the coke
that throws you off you got to get to
the car you gotta get to do a spot now I
gotta go to Aurora 30 minutes and drive
back with it when you get to The Comedy
Store everything you want is right there
for you at a time in my life I didn't
need that yeah yeah well did you ever
have a situation like that like that
well Jimmy was it free for you on the on
the on the road because I like no it was
it was the availability it was just
somebody always had it and most people
didn't want to do it by themselves I
mean I'm so glad I mean he's telling
these stories I I got to tell you I mean
I I feel the same way I'm embarrassed by
some of the things and and the the the
the the the I would I mean I wish I had
half the I could go back and take at
least half of those [__] nights back
or half those you know days back I mean
it was like a five or six year run there
was pretty pretty I sat with Leah by the
month ago outside on the side street we
took a ride to the store and we stopped
and got a Yahoo and we were stoned and
we got out and I started telling them
just
and it's not something that I you know
I was just explaining to Lily's a young
guy and when I got into comedy I thought
the world was flat you know
you know when I left New Jersey I had
grown up in a a type of woman
or I thought
that had you know they were straight you
know what I'm saying like for them once
I left I heard about sugar daddies and
women sucking dick and having a husband
for fifty dollars a week I heard all
this [__] sickness that you know you
don't want to live with but in comedy
you better be prepared for it because
you're out there in White America you
don't know all the dick suckers out
there there's people waiting you know
when you when you go to South Dakota to
a [__] army base
and there's 16 women they've been seeing
the same guys you're [__] Elvis to
them even if you don't have a credit
you're the worst comic in the world even
if you don't even need a credit there
they'll suck your dick just because
you're an outsider wow
you've seen the big city yeah tell us
about California are there really a lot
of fans out there walking around in
vegetarians and [__] and you're like I
do not believe they're asking me these
questions wow but I was just telling Lee
about sexual things like things that
happened to me and I was an ugly guy
could you imagine if I was a strong
feature who was handsome with a nice
physique
I'd be tearing it up all I bumped into a
Coke course with Coke animals that you
sit here 10 years late and go let me
look her up on Facebook and now she's
got kids she's got a loving husband
meanwhile you tied her up you let her on
fire she [__] your dick on tape you
know what I'm saying she swallowed your
sword come on her eyeballs you know this
is way before the iPhone you know thank
God there was no iPhone about 15 years
ago guys like you and me would be dead
dead because you know you're a freaky
[__] we didn't Periscope then no I ain't
periscoping that I want people to see me
coming in a minute you know what I'm
saying I'm not gonna do [__] like that
yeah I just I you know you make a great
point I tell you what man that would
have been that would have been I I'm
glad social media or the phones weren't
around we had enough problems with a
[__] bundle let alone a [__]
iPhone and [__] Periscope and that
[__] holy smokes
it was just a different time and now
yeah I've said it a thousand times
comedy is a different animal there's
nobody pulling a Mitch Hedberg on the
road no more there's nobody well you
know using drugs there's nobody going
dog last weekend just [__] dude in
Cleveland drank 82 shots and caused the
fight that doesn't even happening no
there's no bad people like that in
comedy no more I gotta tell you it's uh
you know I mean most of the people you
know are you sober or on their way to
being sober and
don't drink anymore it's become like a
job now because people
dude I remember the story about Ollie
Joe Prater and Ali Joe Prater there's
his legendary dude apparently he was a
install everybody's jokes but he was
this kind of human cartoon of a
character's like 70 Sam looking like
real life how much did he weigh uh he
was about 350 about 350. no he was a lot
bigger wow towards the end he was but in
his Heyday it's about 350. huge about
five five yeah his big cowboy hat in his
big beard and I remember I was the
runner for the comedy star the guy was
like Mitzi was one of mitzi's guys she
loved him and he's like man could you do
me a favor and he was a huge guy like
big as like 350 370 but he was a small
guy just a big fat round dude in it like
and dude this guy I this guy will walk
up and he's getting ready to feature
axon and he's in the back of the rooms
and he pulls that little 250 gram vials
yeah
right up each National who and he had
been drinking all day he drank like a
case of Moosehead and he goes he's up on
stage for a couple minutes and he wipes
his arm he wipes his nose with his arm
and his blood from the elbow down to the
wrist and oh he goes he goes what's the
matter nobody party anymore
holy [__] but you will never you won't
see any of that anymore because it's
become a bit I mean look man I like it's
so funny because like you're right you
got you got a podcast you gotta do this
I mean there's stuff to do now there
wasn't stuff to do back then you could
sleep to 12 get up burp fart open a beer
go back to bed whatever you want I mean
you know the road was like when you were
doing this it was crazy it was it was
fun but it's it's become something
different now and you got to change with
the times or you'll become obsolete he's
you said Joe he said there's no one
crazy anymore and I'm proud of this fact
but I think we might be The Crazy Ones
800 milligrams we're doing mushrooms
acid
it's a different style like crazy you
know Kennison was crazy Guns and Roses
at the Grammys
that's crazy when everybody's on heroin
and you're on national TV and their
heads are spinning and they're smoking
cigarettes and they're looking at each
other they don't know where they're at
and you know one of them had to be
[__] 9-1-1 to get there you know you
have no idea
what uh you have no idea even towards
the end
Let's Pretend towards the end of the
last two years of my comedy on coke I
was like Kevin Hart
it would have been
ugly what do you mean like because he
didn't have the resources could you
imagine having that addiction with the
resources it would be crazy and and I
said something like that to a friend of
ours who's is in the program and I go
man I go you know I could imagine if he
didn't have anything going on if nothing
was going on in your life I could see
you going to get in the [__] Grand
and snowing I'm staying all night and he
said no it's the opposite he goes now I
mean you got everything going on you get
everything to lose and you have means to
do it and you just you know you just
have that attic personality going yeah
man maybe I'll and you you're right I
mean I mean Kenneth is almost freaking
OD'd you know he wrapped his vet around
a telephone pole you know he's in this
sounds studio with Cheap Trick and
they're going no we'll give you a ride
home we'll give you a ride home and he
wanted to be you know rock and roll if
you see what I gotta put up with next
you know he wraps his vet around a
telephone pole you know are you
imaginingly I'm just can you imagine if
every two nights you got a call
they gotta come pick up Joey Diaz you
got to come bail out Joey Diaz you got
to go to a bank and get two million
dollars to post bail because Joey do you
remember towards the end of Tupac
like this you're too youngly
the last four years of Tupac's life
I mean he got into a shootout with
[__] cops League
Jesus he got shot in the nut
West Coast you know if you look up
Tupac's last four years he got charged
with rape and they threw him in jail and
Suge Knight had to put up a million
dollar bill to get him out and he signed
them in the [__] prison and that's
when he wrote The Double album that's
classic that's [__] nobody's ever
done that nobody's ever done he wrote an
album while he was locked the [__] up
and Suge Knight came to visit him and
said what do you need little brother he
goes I need to post bail for my appeal
he gave him the million dollars or the 5
million you know don't [__] quote me
on this and by the time he got out he
went right from that [__] prison he
said you gotta go get make get that
paper back and you know when you got a
gun to your head you'll [__] rap like
[__] you know yeah slim jim Magoo and
that's that big [__] album that's
that double album that came out if my
memory serves me right heavy bro he
wrote Beyond he wrote it in the joint he
wrote it which makes sense Man Lee he
was in the news Lee every three weeks
and I'm not talking Justin Bieber
getting beat up in Cleveland I'm talking
he was Hardcore last night with the cops
undercover cop him and some of his
buddies it was like when Tyson was on
top the morning I woke up
you know like two days earlier I was up
that's why I used to get Coke there was
two spots in New York City I used to get
Coke on 143rd Street and on 148th Street
no I know I'm lying to you guys 135th
and Amsterdam
but up the corner from that spot there
was little Bodega and I gotta tell you
something Jimmy Schubert from 1979 to
1985 I copped at that joint not because
the cocaine was good but because up the
corner there was a fried chicken giant
some Puerto Ricans would cook chicken 24
hours a day late I wouldn't be able to
pull you away I know you Lee you would
just pitch a tent you would sling drugs
just to eat fried chicken that's how
good the chicken was and they had a
little dog on the front of that if he
didn't like his dog attacked you you had
to go you had to walk no no this is real
this is 1980s but the [__] point I'm
trying to lay on you [__] I
don't even [__] know Jesus Christ
what was I saying
have a brain for you we're talking about
the uh where you used to cop use the cop
at this place in this place yeah but
that was a different time period I'm you
know the point we're trying to make is
um the guy getting arrested all the time
Tupac Tupac so I [__] one night I
read how [__] uh no not Tupac this is
the night that Mike Tyson fought the guy
in the street the other boxer with bare
Knuckles green
remembering out of nowhere on the demise
of Mike Tyson yeah that was the
beginning before it all went down Lee he
got into a [__] fist fight in Harlem
at three in the morning I got a question
you big Mike what were you doing in
[__] Harlem he was getting that
chicken it was like a food stand
ah so it was a popular food stand a lot
of people would you say uh so it was one
one Thirty fifth in Amsterdam it used to
be 135 in Amsterdam from for me from
1981 to about 1985 that was one of my
spots and let me tell you the funniest
thing yeah man you were up above
110th Street turned me on
my high school
teacher told me he goes listen you
didn't hear this from me but the best
Coke and [__] up in Manhattan is
135th and Amsterdam park your car a
block away walk up and right in the
middle is a [__] club walk to the
window
just talk to them in Spanish
that's exactly what I did and in those
days they would sell me
when I first started going to them it
was 250 and 100. so 250 a gram 100 a
gram but it was
and these guys would shoot in that
because it was their own little private
disco and they hit it in the doors they
would put the door jamb down and they
would hide the Coke in there and they
would have two little dj boots uh
turntables and in the middle they would
have an electronic scale so they had a
dance going on you walk straight to the
back the DJ would be mixing and they'd
be wearing your blah blah blah aluminum
foil foil [__] perfectly bam and you
walked out the door with security
somebody walked into his car
walk you out to the street and that went
on 24 7. but in the night time they had
the club in the daytime they had rooster
fights
oh yeah this was the real deal one day
we got then they shot a dude outside he
was dead and I still cop there was a
dude outside from the whole organization
was it an event or why did they shoot a
guy it was a it was a good Saturday
night it was hot out the Yankees lost
you know how it goes Doug I don't know
leave they just shot him on the street
we got there and the cops were there you
know with the the the blanket on the
floor I mean it was 40 feet away from me
but one of the guys that was in that
disco was out there and he saw you and
he goes go around the corner even with
the cops right there 100 yards away they
were weighing it right there in an
Alleyway yeah just a different you you
could never do it now you have cameras
yeah you got cameras everywhere
everybody's got smartphones and
everything else I mean you is I'm
shocked by the Tupac stuff I like
granted I haven't done a lot of like
research oh yeah you have it everything
I've Seen On TV is like no why do you
think that he was Joe why do you think
he started to unwind like that you just
think the success got to him do you
think what what do you think I mean
could you say okay and basically you
have life [__] if you can behave
yourself if you could behave yourself
you're putting out these albums you're
making millions of dollars you got Life
Dick at least you can get a [__]
house
becomes a reality like situation there
life is that a great heart
you know right now I'm sitting here
let's pretend for some reason
I start getting into theaters
every time I do a theater Lee's going to
come to me and go listen
a guy at the door he says he wants to be
a writer for you
he comes in the guy remember you told me
a story about Kenneth I went to a club
in Chicago and one of Kenneth's favorite
comic was a comic from Chicago that's a
school teacher he's still there now he
works on radio and TV oh Steve Dahl
Steve died no a different guy okay I
just bumped him to him he's old he's got
six kids Irish Catholic he has a bit
about the bus driver with the Snickers
and the oh the candy the candy candy of
course yeah you know yeah that guy's
still in Chicago and now he uh it's like
a dude at the radio station
you know he's still a comic and he made
it that was making it for him and I'm
happy for him he's a [__] great guy
what is his name
I remember I'm talking about this bit
though it's hilarious but you know even
at the end Let's Pretend let's talk
about Candace in here Kennison was great
how many dirty dogs was Candace and
dragon with him how many guys were on
this case telling him he was great
giving him cocaine that happens at every
level not in this Society no no I I
agreed absolutely 100 and then you know
I I happen to be torn with the dude but
I mean I you know I went on another tour
with him because I wasn't one of those
guys and we took out me and a guy named
Dan Barton because we you know there was
no there was no drugs I mean some of
these guys that you're out there with
like you know Mitch Walter this guy
could [__] score blowing a [__]
Convent I'm not even joking I'm not
joking no he's a bad [__] yeah
he's still out there yeah he is he just
got his [__] hit replaced I talked to
him once in a while you know but I mean
he's one of those guys I mean you talk
about being a grifter you talk about the
term grifter and the way the guy was a
card mechanic now he was a card mechanic
but the guy was a crypt he played the
[__] horses I mean he griffed his way
through [__] life you know and you
know hooked up with Kenneth and then and
like you said you know the the I mean it
was like a way of life you know people
don't realize you're surviving and
fighting for every [__] nickel and
you know so but yeah he uh yeah he's
still out there one of the funniest
[__] dudes too one of the funniest
guys pound for pound I can always make
me [__] Laugh In fact Richard Pryor
thanks him I'm one of the albums yeah
because Mitchell used to write all the
people yeah
for laughing like you know these were
the caliber guys I mean there's Carla
Beau Mitch Walters Allen Stevens these
guys are [__] legendary [__]
comedians that were around the store
doing the [__] during the during the
strike and and guys and and you know
these you know guys before like a class
you know probably two classes before
mine these guys were hanging out and
just you know it was uh it was a great
education to me when I got to the store
I thought it was like college you know I
mean really I get to sit there and watch
Robin Williams go up and I mean you know
when I was there I got there 86 84 like
the end 85 beginning 86 it's it was like
dude it was it was ridiculous 85
86. so you've been lurking for 31 years
the other day at the airport you said
you know what
maybe it's time to pack up my bag and do
the dream away you know Jimmy Schubert
guys like you want me to dream never
goes away and in a way you ever see the
John Gotti Junior interview for 60
minutes no and he goes what happens if
you get hit and he goes are you [__]
kidding me I made it to the age of 51.
I did things that nobody does because
nobody you know just being on a set one
time for me would have made my life
complete I would at least some of the
loser Edge would have gone away from
myself even in the [__] big movie
even on television show that didn't
matter for me at the time yeah all I
wanted was when I first came to La all I
wanted was
just to survive when I became a regular
at the store it was the first time I was
part of something like that I I stuck to
my p's and q's as good as I could I'm
happy I never got caught [__] up and
bailed Island I'm still welcome there
yeah we're lucky
these guys that they went up to and said
don't come back here no more like don't
let it die yeah the new town court and
they just told people either you're too
old or don't come back that's why I
don't call more than twice a week down
there because I feel old as it is yeah
but you know here's the other thing too
it's like you know you still [__]
wrong I mean you look you and look at
[__] you know Don Rickles I mean God
bless some guy's [__] 90s still doing
it I mean he's Don Rickles for God's
sakes but look at Joan Rivers I mean you
see that documentary my favorite
documentary about being a stand-up comic
ever is the Joe Murray's documentary uh
about
um you know piece of work I mean here
she is 78 every bit as funny as anybody
30 years her [__] Junior takes
private [__] Jets to our [__]
events works on the The Shopping Channel
selling [__] she's got her her daughter
Melissa she's taking care she's doing
the fashion police I mean look at this
bro I mean she was a [__] icon and
and just and still going it's 78.
and died doing something she loved to do
you know getting getting the surgeries
but listen No but I mean God rest your
soul but I mean I mean she I mean look
at that I mean you're right but look at
because you're still relevant you're
still doing it but I know what you're
saying it's a little freaky I sit there
all the time it's like I'm living in a
[__] dream
I'm living in a [__] fantasy like I I
go to Philadelphia the place is packed
you talk to people afterwards people you
know it's like a fantasy like I'm
opening up for Nick de Paulo in Dallas
I'm going it's as good as it's ever
going to get for me like this but yeah
but yeah you know like and that's an
honest [__] reaction like no it is
and look at all and look where you come
from and all the [__] you've been
through I gotta tell you something I
catch myself sometimes because you
forget I mean you're too busy you keep
going you got to keep moving you keep
moving sometimes when you find yourself
you're sitting there and you just catch
yourself going wow I did that and I was
able to do that I was able to check that
off my list and get this done and this
thought and all wow and all while like
you said doing all that [__] crazy
[__] I mean I I get up every day today I
I thank God every day I would get out of
bed and I I feel like a blessed man and
I'm still able to make a living doing
something I love to do and I'm really
good at it
resurrect our old managers
Jeff Gatlin we're trying to resurrect
this guy because
you guys have no idea the intensity of
this Jewish Bulldog I mean his great
great uncle was definitely there to
stick the nail in Jesus's foot this guy
was a torture chamber if you ever heard
him on the phone talking of casting
people whatever and I gotta tell you
something
I've been here 19 years he still pulled
off a Houdini move and the man is right
here Jimmy Schubert has an audition for
a pilot and this [__] clown decides
to pick up abroad and he's taking a
coaching horses and gets his balls
licked and he goes in the next day and
he drank coffee and he got all paranoid
and he ran out of there Chef get one got
him back in there
the next day and they told the casting
director that Jimmy Schubert had drank
too much coffee he stayed up all night
drinking coffee Jeff Gatlin did a move
that nobody's ever done
that nobody's ever pulled it's like the
only person who pulled that move on was
Audrey Meadows when she went to see
Jackie Gleason and he told her she was
too pretty and the next day he she hired
a photographer and took pictures of her
in the morning with no makeup right and
he showed him the pictures and Ralph
course that's her I won who is she and
he goes same broad that was here
yesterday
and he was blown away dude Jeff Gatlin
sets up an audition for me I'm coming in
he picks me up at the [__] airport
with my bags drives me to the audition
waits for me to come out
and I go and then [__] took me back
to my joint I go there's no manager in
the history of managers that I've ever
met in my [__] life that would do
something like that and that's what a
real [__] manager does I wound up
getting that job that job was for one
hour photo there must have been 300 guys
going to read for the role of the
[__] soccer coach it wasn't a big
part it was a little part I got to work
on a three days with Robin Williams I
had to show him this photo I got this
great picture of me I'm on stage I gotta
be 1920 in the original room as a
picture of me there's a picture of Robin
Williams and Sam Kinison they both got
microphones and they're looking at me
and I was this [__] young kid I
didn't know you weren't supposed to go
on stage and then doing this improv
[__] exercise and it's one of my
favorite pictures I'll [__] show it
to you uh after the thing but it's it's
it's it's a black and white photo in the
original Circa 1987.
it's me from Williams and Sam commission
and I am the only [__] still
alive in the [__] picture Jesus
Christ put that picture away please put
that picture away I don't want to bring
no bad spirits in him no no chicken no
bring him down oh God God bless that
picture
I got one guy who got Diamond the other
guy God forbid please get those bad
spirits out of here we might as well
talk about politics again
I didn't mean to I didn't mean to run
through your bubble guard someone
brought it to me someone brought it to
my [__] attention let me give some
shout outs here to some great [__]
people first of all my main cousin
ham cell Diaz always posting pictures of
my other cousin from Cuba he put do you
see the pictures
and [__] Peter Gabriel how about a
shout out to my man Brady Ferguson
Darren McGinnis Lonnie Collins J.R Gomez
Crystal with the new [__] hairdo and
Bobby
spooky spooky Cleo Jonathan Santa Brea
David marwin Marin and Jim none your
[__] business [__] you know I
love you guys and don't forget Felicia's
at Flappers all weekend two shows Friday
two shows Saturday uh I'll be posting
the no expectation tour in L.A working
up to my special I got one two three
four five six seven hours from July 21st
to October 11th to put this thing
together Jimmy Shoup is going to be a
contributing writer he didn't know I
know she's working pro bono anyway uh
that's it I love you [__]
always be safe this weekend you know
yeah you were just [__] around with
the fireworks Joey thanks for having me
in bro no no I'm not done here hold on
I
want to pick up the pieces up above
110th Street somebody breaks your heart
hold on one second yeah let's fill this
[__] that's
hilariously I was on uh Freddy krayz
podcast thanks for the invite number
100. thank you very much if you want to
check that out that'd be great it was a
really fun podcast
they don't have enough on their [__]
plate now they gotta listen to another
podcast yes they do because Freddie's a
great comic and Freddie is a good
[__] dude here you go who's up first
give it to Lee Lee's ready I'm already
dead that's okay that's good what do you
mean okay that's okay
put away the whip the horse is dead you
know what I'm saying let's do this [__]
this is your father you've been
breathing like Dr belisas your lungs
should be a tip top [__] for dude
right now you know how to do this you're
a professional I know I'm working for
the [__] listen obviously there's
nothing knowing how to do it isn't the
issue listen obviously there's not going
to be a [__] uh Olympia in Brazil we
might as well have our little Olympian
this [__] room yeah Brazil spent all
their money bribing uh the Olympic
officials we got the games there they
didn't even count on the zika virus and
you get the [__] medals come on hurry
up While We're Young here what are we
what are we thinking about it's a little
bunk it's a little
I know an eight-year-old that does a
bigger that [__] come on let's go this
is [__] up
yeah I know you're right
hit that Soldier
yeah
no no we're here
look at him go leave your [__] animal
look at you suck it there you go look at
you you're like Prince in 1999 give me
that [__] thing yeah I'll fill it up
for you
watch out Let Me Burn some of the germs
off look at this poor bastards
I don't know
I like black
[Laughter]
this is
oh [__]
[__] you think you're dealing with
[__] you want a piece of this
machine I'm good man what's the story
you know no no no no I'm just hanging
out with you two guys I'm sitting
between you two guys
[Laughter]
stop over there more pockets and [__]
spaghetti from La Villa oh that's
exactly where I'm going dog do you think
Pagliacci's bro I think you're [__]
dealing dude have you ever been there
man I played being a magician eat that
[__] thing
I remember those two patients in here
I remember getting coked out with two
pages if you don't think I want to kill
the pigeons
oh that's [__] hilarious bro that's
hilarious Joey
the whole thing the [__] star routine
like Lee used to do
yeah
no dude I'm fine I had like 18 I had
like four ball hits I'm telling you in
training it never ends though like at
least basic training ends basic training
that runs even black belts [__] go to
work every day you have a Sam Miller
you're a black belt [__] getting it
together look at the [__] great
things you've done Lee look where you've
come from zero to 100 you're like Drake
you've come zero to 100 real
[__] quick you understand me
it's pretty crazy I mean how great I
mean who the [__] knows what what we
were talking about before the podcast
went on it was
you know when you're 22 you have these
expectations of what you want to do your
parents have this expectation of what
you want to do because it's like [__]
what's his name they do leave your
parents I'm just thinking about my
parents your poor parents have
expectations they help you through
solids they brought you big ziti they
brought you brownies just so you can
lean in the direction and you did well
you did well most most people do well
but guess what happens you do get a job
in your field and that's it this is I
gotta work indoors
[__] 10-6 it's [__] 82 degrees huh
and all some people go you know what
I'm Gonna Keep mine alone I'm gonna
start Landscaping
and you start Landscaping with a dude
and he likes you and it gives you a
raise then it gives you a route and one
day the guy comes to you and goes I got
10 days to live you want to buy the
business for 8 000 and you bought a
business and hey you're making 200 000 a
year and you sit there and go what was
that econ degree for
that happens every [__] day oh dude
we came out here took a chance to come
out here be an editor and also the
podcast thing [__] blew up wait a
film editor uh that would have been a
dream I did reality TV reality TV would
you work in Final Cut Pro I have it I
haven't yeah what are you Johnny edited
all of a sudden no no yeah I had some
project I had to stick to what you know
I guess he's mad he knows about cheese
what do you know about
see right now if this is 20 years or I
could take you in the back and have 10
dudes smack you around because I know
we're not moving I love you
follow me
by the way I was thinking about this as
I was leaving my house today and come
over you know I mean they have never
like I mean no once in a blue moon
because but there was never like the
movies they made in the [__] 70s
Serpico oh please I mean there's nothing
you're beating up a dead horse we've
destroyed that [__] subject not even
[__] close I was thinking about it I
mean it's just so funny going you know
because you were someone I was telling
someone like that goes who's a [__]
movie star there's no more movie stars
who sells [__] tickets Marvel and
[__] robots yeah but that's [__]
nobody there's no stars I mean we have
no American hero Jimmy you know why
because
1932 we've had John Wayne yeah we've had
tough guys have you know uh uh the guy
who did the original Scarface I forget
what his name was then you had Edward G
Robinson and then you had all these
people the guy who did War of the Worlds
and then you had these men who were men
they showed pictures of them before most
addressed with suits having cocktails
with women dressed nicely yeah they all
suck dick but don't get confused it was
a different era when I was growing up
you had Clint Eastwood Charles Bronson
you know you had these people that and
then Rocky Balboa came along yeah you
had these people you look who do you
look up to now a [__] robot well I
want to be like Superman you can't fly
stupid yeah that it's ridiculous I mean
I'm telling you and and the funny thing
is is like they're all they all I was so
funny what was I watching that movie uh
the Hatfield The McCoys the one that was
on TNT like a couple years back with the
Costner and and these actors and I go
out of this driving range over what's it
I'm gonna hit a couple golf balls and
I'm sitting there I said no that is
nobody there the guy sitting in the neck
I walk and I put my bags out and a guy
in the next dog oh you just didn't have
Phil McCoys as well
you know in in the movie he had this
Tennessee accent he's an English guy to
roll English actors all the English
actors or the Australians they'll come
here and they take these jobs there's
nothing a [__] American in the
[__] lot there's not an American in
the [__] lot I mean other than other
than Tom Cruise and [__] who's
selling [__] tickets Brad Pitt I
haven't seen it you know
I mean it's right nobody's really
selling tickets because we don't see the
bottom line we don't see what they do in
China we don't see what they do in
Australia and all those markets that's
where they make their secondary they'll
Cry Wolf to you here in the states they
had a losing [__] Market they don't
lose a dime those [__] are
gonna deal with Vietnamese underground
television to have their movie played on
them that's what people don't know yes
forget about the work and film situation
that is what has made guys like you and
I God bless us
lucky yeah because guys that we were
character actors what was the okay we
just uh quoted a movie earlier [__]
uh sleepers
that guy
and you were in the same category oh
yeah [__] years it was his name and
they finally game a TV show
think he's on something now but he looks
completely different yeah and he's a
good actor no he's a great actor yeah
that was the league you were in back
there you were right there yeah but
every time you went to an audition he
was lurking he was like he was there and
freaking you know a couple development
is a couple of deals that I had we shot
a pilot a couple had a couple of those
working and then I I came up against
guys with like you know it was yeah
you're right I mean I had I had a nice
stretch there for like you know about
five or five or six years just where you
could go in and you could I mean look
back then you pick up a you pick up a
guest star on freaking ER you go in
there you work for a couple days you're
gonna make like you know but but that
now all the residuals from that went
back when the SAG contracts were there I
mean dude now everything is I can't tell
you guy what's up buddy oh well you were
talking about selling tickets and it's
crazy they're selling tickets to some of
them but they're just
they're breaking these records but
ticket prices are so high I just went
and
out of the top ever movies
what number do you think was the top
grossing ever like out of every movie
ever what number do you think was a
2000.
tell me yeah
number
there's Jaws in there yeah so it doesn't
get to number 11. the top 10 grossing
movies all time were before 2000 and
even before that like
I think before 19. well you have more
longevity I know but I keep replaying
them in markets I mean there's a lot of
variables yeah
they keep selling me the same movie so
if I seen Transformers one I've seen
Transformers too I've seen Transformers
3 I've seen the whole [__] thing
you're just remaking the same [__]
movie over and over again and selling it
listen right now where you were hitting
on earlier
I just said since it's just some
somebody just sent me something on
Twitter
and they they sent me a twit saying that
they've signed on to shoot Death Wish
and Lee and I sat here for two hours
figuring out who's gonna play Charles
Bronson and some people sent me Steve
Buscemi and that's like gonna [__]
work some people sent me [__] things
that were
ridiculous they were ridiculous they
were so far out of the game and it's not
their fault this is the [__] they've
been sold
hey man I heard your conversation on the
podcast I I think you should go with
Steve buscember you know I think you
should go with the who else that they
recommend
oh God they break away at the American
Sniper do they have never too good
looking no no first off they can't
remake Death Wish do you know why you
can't why don't you start a new movie
because the rape scene is so
[__] real brutal yeah that it would
never work today it's like the beginning
of The Longest Yard it would never work
on it but we don't take that [__] and
smack them in the mouth and throws her
against a wall that would never work on
television though
every every like eight minutes Lee
realizes how high he is and he tilts his
head back and he says a prayer going
like but in all that whole two seconds
he thinks about how he got here and why
he still comes here on a daily basis and
how he could get right now leave town
with Paul and never come back he doesn't
need this he's a nice Jewish boy
there may be a route plan it was really
great seeing you the other day Jimmy
Schubert because
that day I didn't Focus that night I
didn't focus on anything negative
I have nothing negative to focus on
right now I in my eyes lasted 15 years
longer that when I anticipated and you
know what I did get into some good movie
speaking of sad contracts I just got my
second residual check from Grudge Match
and you don't want me to tell you what
it is how bad it is
it's embarrassing bad what I made on
that movie but it doesn't matter to me
it was an opportunity yeah I was there
to fill the void for me it wasn't even
about the money it was about having the
opportunity to be in the room with those
dudes I'm an ex-fucking felon I was
living in a rocket ship I was stealing
drugs I was doing all these [__] then
I came out here and got even worse at
one point I was so [__] bad out here
I still remember feeling a chick at the
Denny's on Sunset by Rock and Roll Ross
under the table I was eating hamburgers
and they're looking at me going are you
[__] serious
like on coke in my mind she was ready to
[__] go she asked me to sit down and
get a cheeseburger
I'm like let's get a cheeseburger okay
you're a comedian great she had a mini
skirt on and like grabbed that [__]
kneecap and she looked at me like you
come again I'm like what's the story
here nobody asked me to have a [__]
cheeseburger she's like you better get
up and get the [__] out of here to pay
for both cheeseburgers and run out of
there before she died 9-1-1
yeah and now you're there and now you're
doing from all that what I'm saying is
sometimes you gotta stop and think about
that because you go I mean that is
winning that's a victory I mean you know
we were I know at one point in my life I
was out there on the [__] Edge but
you know you're able to come back from
it gonna control your life and look
you're wearing a [__] movie with
Robert De Niro I mean come on that's
[__] impressive and you [__]
killed it too bro I mean you did a
[__] [__] toe-to-toe with [__] a
Robert De Niro what was was this acting
101 huh Joey Coco Diaz methadone actor
he went [__] but I know but I'm
saying dude you went from dude you're
telling that story about
basketballs basketballs or whatever you
went from that to doing scenes with the
Nero
Joey sometimes you're gonna give you
some bread though you know you know what
you're right I did I came back Jesus
Christ you you sit I sit there sometime
listen there's not a day at one point
when I'm showering
or when I sit down I'm eating
that before nine o'clock I go back in my
mind somewhere where like I'm like where
was I 22 years ago or something
look at my living room and look at the
balcony and I look at the cats and
I got these two cats that are two
brothers Harry and Demi let's pretend I
get hit by a [__] car tomorrow
one of my greatest achievements is I
save both those Brothers I look at them
every night and every night they sleep
next to each other with their heads next
to each other no they don't yes they do
yes they do so they all one goes west
and one goes east but the head's two or
three inches apart and at one point Demi
who's [__] pops his [__] head up
looks around wakes up and he gets closer
to his brother and starts licking his
neck right and that goes on for about
three minutes until Harry wakes up out
of his trance and he's like wait a
second this ain't a [__] wet dream
it's my brother licking my neck which
means I have to lick his neck and I'll
sit there stoned to the gills watching
Harry licking them his neck and Debbie
and this will go on for six or seven
minutes then they get more aggressive
then Harry puts one pull up the to hold
Demi because he's moving too much but
Demi doesn't get it like his brother
goes I'll lick your neck but stop
[__] moving stop [__] moving
already but Demi like gets offended and
also they start swinging at each other
for like eight seconds they just drove
bop bop bop bop and then one of them
jumps off shakes his head and then back
to normal he drinks water and they lay
right back next to each other and I'm
like that is my greatest accomplishment
that somebody knocked on that door and
said we'll take the one count I'll never
forget I'm looking at my wife and going
let's give it a shot no we'll take them
for a while and now that's my greatest
but I swear I'm so happy I did that
those two [__] and I'll tell
you what their bond is so strong when we
moved we left one cage with one down
there and we brought the other one Harry
couldn't live without his brother
making the weirdest noises
with his [__] mouth it was scary as
[__] when we brought Demi back they both
started making the noise then they
snapped out of it like Dr Doolittle and
they went back to meowing or whatever
the [__] they thought you know what I'm
saying they're here for one of your
friendliest cats I love Harry
but it's a pleasure
to have you on I got to tell you
something one of the happiest days of my
life is where somebody was telling me
that they I went back to New York and
I did this David tell show and I really
kicked ass and I go who else was on and
they were like such and such and such
and such but they looked me in the
eyeball and they go you know [__]
destroyed them
and when they said Jimmy Schubert
I got goosebumps and I was really happy
but the first thing I thought of
two words
art
work yeah that's I swear to my mother's
grave that's the first thing that came
to my mind I go
you know hard work and then the next
thing was
I'm not surprised
you [__] are surprised because
you guys don't do movies or whatever
Jimmy never stopped doing stand-up now
let me tell you something in 1997 when I
met Jimmy Schubert he was a real [__]
headliner
so if that was close to [__] 20 years
ago what do you think he's doing now
playing hopscotch Let's Pretend he gets
this much better every year can you
imagine and this is a guy that's still
doing
300 plus sets in [__] Beijing and
Australia and troops and you do 300 sets
a year that's what you do as your
training to get to the store those first
five six years of Comedy if you don't
have a lot with 300 plus sets you're not
gonna make it your legs aren't going to
be that strong when you come out here
you've been doing that since I met you
but you know who else has been doing
that huh me too my brother that's right
my brother and we're both that's crazy
that's crazy that we kept doing it we
what did I tell you on the drive home I
said this [__] is not fair because the
funniest guy working out there that
still has a craft beside guys like Jimmy
Schubert is a guy like David tell yeah
and but since David tell doesn't have a
podcast or he's not hip or this or not
me I if I'm into stand up at all levels
I want to see it at all levels listen
man I've said it a thousand times
totally I love the puppet guy he
entertained when I'm stoned I'm a [__]
Jeff whatever Jeff Dunham and people I
[__] go gym
let me tell you we all have different
[__] taste and then to see guys
suffer on the road because you haven't
been in a movie in two years years or
doesn't make sense to me ah god dude I
did and I'll tell you man and it's not a
life for everybody and like you said you
talked about you know you know I I've
learned to become my own best friend on
their own and on you know I don't do
carry on nearly
at all I mean I drink coffee and I do my
thing and I go in there and I'm writing
a new hour right now I just recorded my
last hour my new uh my new special be
out soon it's called Zero Tolerance we
did the whole thing produced it myself
financed it myself if I can boom one in
there a set of four cameras shot in a 4K
redid the whole joint it looks [__]
great I just got done doing the
voiceover for the opening animation but
you got to keep creating and that's the
one thing you got to keep going at it
it's like you said I mean dude before I
I got here I mean this guy's like you
know
um
Jeff uh what was his Jeff Altman a guy
would tour with the same set for 40 for
20 years with the same 45 minutes but
that's what everybody did back then now
people are writing a new [__] hour
every year I mean it's crazy but if
that's what you want to do but you know
I mean look at the guys like will we see
Katie come on it's just not enough to be
the funniest guy anymore you better be
acting create your own series you got to
be doing all that just they raised the
bar man it became a real job and thank
God you know we're talking about our
carrying on and all that silly [__] we
did it's become a real job now you got
to work at it right absolutely right and
and and the thing is it's like well
great that's that's [__] awesome you
know that you're out there you're doing
it but it's but I still love it I still
like making people laugh I still love
that human because there's nothing I've
done in my [__] life that comes close
to walking in front of a room full of
[__] 250 people and just [__] just
knocking it out of the [__] Park what
about the pigeons you like that I I
still do a little bit of magic here in
it yeah sure
you don't know if they flipped already I
don't know if they got a wire on them
[__] know and they want canaries they
were pigeons oh my God you know you have
no idea where you go through with all
your friends Jimmy Schubert I'm happy I
saw you the other day it made me feel
better about myself yeah man me too dude
I'm glad we're able to hook up and do
that
what will your next couple dates uh next
couple that would be Chicago in July I'm
going back to Philly just to visit my
family with my girl and uh you know
she's gonna go back to school there and
affiliate Temple I'm going to see my mom
and dad hang out my brother Joey said
I'm gonna stay at my brother Joey's
joint see my nieces and stuff he's not
going to do that thing where you rent
the room in somebody's house and you eat
dinner with them like the commercial oh
the the Airbnb yeah I better [__] do
that
go stay with my family I got friends and
family back there my brother my brother
told me that because I got the rumors no
because it's
a generation wants to stay at creepy
people's house and take a chance like go
to the country rooms hold on let me open
it yesterday
I can't wait back when it's traveling
comedy and doing the road I was [__]
stating comedy condos that's all the air
[__] B and B once again some [__]
opening act jerked off into the
mayonnaise you couldn't [__] eat
nothing I just can't wait till people
start
oh it's already happened perverts that
is
oh Airbnb cameras we speak there's a
perverted filthy people that said oh my
God wait a second I can rent a house to
a family and get the whole family in one
bedroom this is Paradise
this has to be this is to watch watch
where Airbnb goes well let me tell you
something I remember Airbnb first came
out I was checking around and I was
looking I was looking for like a
vacation spot and you could rent a
[__] giant TP in [__] uh and and
uh uh somewhere in Colorado for like an
Airbnb it was like a giant kind of it
had bunks in it and stuffy but it was a
giant teepee go back there and have that
experience if you want you know what I'm
saying I don't want that experience you
know what I'm saying cheese Chief Two
talks all I got to do is send Lee and my
right now if this was 30 years ago all I
have to do is suddenly around the
country I need to check out houses and
tell me where they put the key and I'll
do the rest a week later we don't know
nothing
we don't know nothing what are you
talking about I'm not a burger I'm a
computer [__] nerd I came over here
to go to a [__] Comic-Con I even
bought tickets what are you talking
about he was so look at my record I'm
Jewish I don't have you [__] suit my
uncle will [__] own that [__]
Airbnb house it'll be called sayat BMB
understand me and let me ask you a
question you get a Cheesesteak when you
filling no I didn't yeah good for you
would you uh 53 years old I got one for
the grade one a banana peel uh
I go wrestle with young kids today I
slept four hours last night but I went
to the I couldn't go I had a meeting at
once I couldn't go to jiu jitsu so
instead I went to the whatever class I
go down there you gotta look at your
[__] thing now and go huh you know
every time I go down to the drug blood
I'm waiting for bad news I gotta go to
Bob Hope next Tuesday at 9 45 and give
them blood right now you know where my
head is right now and hell hell I'm
thinking about right now during the
podcast tonight yeah I was thinking
about when you were talking about
politics I went crazy in this
[__] yeah that's what happened
Lisa yet what's up with you my brother
sitting there like a zombie de la Moke
talk to me you bad [__] who
loves you more than Uncle Joe your dad
was here yeah what do you got this
weekend what do you got tonight you're
going out you swinging dick what are you
doing
no I'm not doing nothing I'm doing today
no disco's this weekend with the
girlfriend
we might do something exactly it's funny
when you guys are talking about doing
stuff Facebook has this feature now like
on this day
and it's I look back and it's always
like going to work doing homework okay
like I feel like having any done like a
whole bunch of [__] well stop writing
stupid [__] on there that'll [__]
stop I see every two [__] things from
you I'm like what's he talking about why
is he on Facebook talking about this
[__]
uh what are you talking about on there
half the time I don't know you're at
home eating Stars your periscopes are
very good but your Facebook I don't know
what you're talking about I don't know
man you tell me the plan
what the [__] the stupid joke I was
really hot well next time call your mom
and tell her run it past her first
before you put it on Facebook all right
if she giggles then put it on Facebook
you're gonna put a trump joke that joke
hurt my [__] feelings why because
there's something about fat people going
to Canada I need that in my [__] life
Canada won't take me that means they
ship me back to cube I lose 200 pounds
and you're Jewish you stay here and get
an attorney and move back to Boston eat
wings and fast food do you live in your
mama's basement in captivity
the [__] in hiding
whatever the [__] it's called I love you
guys first off let me yell at these
sponsors here that I love with all my
heart number one on it the best my
protein show of choice always the hemp
protein chocolate I know there's the
acai and everything dude I love the
Alpha Brain I had the Alpha Brain I
think the brain is like doing coke
yeah and shrimp tag
is a great product dude I've I've taken
it I've ordered it I love it I can't
wait to do my nose surgery in a way so I
could take those shroom tanks and really
get the cardio going yeah really burned
some fat get some fat off my ass so
don't smell like cheeseburgers
I scratch my ass my dead skin smells
like a sandwich like a Cuban sandwich
from 1982. anyway go to audit.com right
now they got a great selection of
supplements and I'm going to give you 10
off go to the box and press in church on
the way out and I'm gonna give you 10
off gets delivered right to your door
listen and it's a great product the
alpha brand is 100 money back guarantee
and we don't want the product back
slowing it do whatever you're going to
do with it whatever the [__] because
that [__] don't work for you you really
mental problems you'll get focused
you'll have more clearer dreams and
you'll see a different way a [__]
different perspective I'm not telling
you you're going to become Alibaba I
didn't say that to you right I didn't
tell you you're going to go three for
three at the [__] track I never said
that what I said is that you'll pick a
little sharper without Adderall you'll
be a little sharper with [__]
minerals you want me to break them down
for you I can't go to audit.com right
now go to the box and press in church
bam
get 10 offer right that's right get some
Himalayan salt some of that pink
Himalayan salt they sell get a couple
kettlebells
braid on you I can't give you a deal on
the Kettlebell see you're [__] me up
you're breaking my credibility no I'm
not I mean okay number two my people
Chris over there and that's usara
as far as gym bags
the [__] fanny pack the hemp ghee
Comfort It Don't Fit me and I need to
drop like 80 more pounds and then I'll
fit in the [__] ghee but that don't
matter that bag is the bag of many uses
you know why
because I don't know where that bag was
when I was smuggling cocaine
the bag got more secret compartments
it's got a water thing I put the water
in one then I put the backup board I put
the protein powder with the nose spray
and the [__] uh the sweat towels that
you put in water I put my water and cell
phone the one compartment has knee pads
and older knee pads the other thing has
paperwork a pen so if I'm sitting there
I can write something if I forget I mean
it's just a great bag and it comes in
the compartment inside where you can put
your t-shirts and your dirty underwears
and your filthy [__] socks you filthy
[__] suckers go to go to dsgear.com
right now and look at the great
selections they got a great rash guard
for 15 [__] bucks an Eco rash guard
listen they're not [__] around if
you're a jiu jitsu guy go over to
dsgear.com right now and press in Joey
boom I'm giving you five percent off
right off the top that two gets shipped
to your house I want to thank on it I
want to thank drusar I want to thank my
man Chris I want to thank Jimmy Two
Shoes and I want to thank you guys for a
great month and also I want to [__]
all so say happy Fourth of July give me
the national anthem you know what I'm
saying let's [__] do this and don't
give me the game Marines because you
insult me this time I'll stab you one of
these water bottles let's go big let's
go [__] deep let's take him into the
murky Waters of the underworld you
understand me
but listen let's go Lee what's the
problem national anthem
n-a-t-i-o-n-a-l-a-n-t-h-e-m whatever
uh what happened they took it off for
copyright reasons no they took it off my
whatever it's my my Jesus christly I
need for you to have this on [__]
pilot I need for you to be able to press
too
no no no no no no
no what the heavy duty woman I want a
little bit more heart that sounds like
the [__] quad yeah the Boys Town
choir you know after they spent the
night there you know
they're all jammed up they don't want to
sing
up all night back there you want to wear
a robe and put on a Batman episode
what's the story it's got an eagle with
a big Marine in there shooting somebody
as a Chinese guy yelling that's the
video you want that's the national
anthem you want I'm looking for look at
what are you looking for I'm looking for
that was he was playing the
Star-Spangled Banner before whatever I
don't care something American League no
he was over here playing a star strangle
banana bro he's over here no he's
playing something come on Lee hit me
I'm sorry I had it on my thing
why would you take it off I didn't I
don't know what happened
get me a good Anthem Lee you're slowing
down my Pace here Lee I was all
emotional [__] charged up for this
and now that's it you broke the [__]
spirit
I was ready to go off you understand me
oh Jesus Christ it sounds like you after
10 Stars
[Laughter]
just put [__] in the regular song on I
love you guys America [__] raise your
chins your bad [__] we ain't
scared of nobody you understand me
tragedies uh whatever it's here accept
it and [__] go out there with a smile
Grab Your Balls until all these
[__] to suck your dick your
back like [__] hurt hold on one
second
what happened
[__]
what I do have it
this is what I gotta live with
let's see come on Lee let's go
oh Jesus Christ here we go Crank that
[__] meal
break at least
I'm losing my rap here so you started
it's the fourth of July weekend and
never forget you're a [__] American
you understand me
kill you stab whatever the [__] you need
to do you're a [__] American you
understand me stop with the [__]
don't let me catch it on the phone like
a [__] fruitcake Shine Your Shoes
stop [__] crying about the economy
and they're letting immigrants in you
got to outwork the [__] immigrant you
understand me you gotta operate the
Immigrant why should the [__]
Armenians have [__]
[Music]
is
this one you're a dumb [__] you got a
Ford from 1980. grab your [__] heart
salute the flag you [__] dirty I'm
out of words you broke the most forget
about it you you it took too long I was
fired up I had a little sentimental
speech I was gonna shut it to you I
apologize you know I love you I don't
give a [__] let's play some [__]
musically I love you guys we'll be back
Monday ready to [__] rock and roll
thank you have a happy Fourth of July
and keep your fingers [__] you know
don't become a shop teacher because
that's what a guy does when he loses a
finger that's right it doesn't make a
difference you could be a financial
advisor you go around the Fourth of July
you blow off two digits you become a
shop teacher that's it you lose all your
street cred it's your dick together have
a great weekend be safe Uncle Joey loves
you peace goalie
Leah you slipped the time
oh [__]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]